est-ce qu'on n'a pas envie de jouer à
quelques jeux vidés al jarida faire
debout cette vidéo j'avais d'affaires de
bouger pas le bureau cool que les gens
cool on là où tu peux lever espaces
aujourd'hui j'ai pris trois jeux
gratuits bien nawak mais qui vont bien
de faire kiffer le premier s'appelle
spherical constitution et il est bon il
ya une boule et le but c'est de bouger
l'endroit où est la boule pour la faire
atteindre le trou voila voila ca c st
juste a penché et satin le truc mais je
pense que plus tard il faudra faire du
gauche droite voilà il ya du blanc short
son cul finalement puisque je dis aux
oies de pâques à ces horribles sur son
bras
ok faut que je me penche comme ça en
fait pour qu'elle ait de temps après je
crois enfin les contrôles sont nuls un
chien tout ça vous voyez galères et là
on est contrôle de merde pourquoi là
elle est pas dans l es deux ans c'est
quoi cette notion de la 3d je manquais
sont toutes les deux ou trois dans le
jeu et que j'en peux plus mais pourquoi
il la fera c'est comme ça c'est sûr
c'est comme ça regardez j'ai un truc à
moi j'ai réussi
d'accord je n'ai pas fait exprès ça en
dit long sur votre jeu monsieur o mais
c'est quoi cette position au col et
voilà ici
par contre là c'est quand même l'un des
jeux les plus fumeux kahn a joué ces
deux derniers mois franchement oui
[ __ ] ça allait bien ça j'adore mon
gars j'adore je suis nul mais j'adore
ram et l'arrêt ya un petit pont et
obtient à gourcy on va reprendre le
petit pont à chose un tract sur ça
j'aime trop trash sur les jeux ou cvc
nul de traire de redonner un peu d'élan
up et hop beau c'est quand même un bon
jeu de fond ceux des mecs ça c'est les
gens qui vont dans les catacombes tu
vois c'est qu'on est en train d'y jouer
au mais [ __ ] ça part sur un délire de
cercueil qui s'est offerte à le pirée ya
un trou dans le piège parce qu'il faut
bien viser haut
oh et maintenant on peut faire la passe
anna dommage mais tu as joué en fait je
commencerai qui fait je sais ce que je
dois m'inquiéter un peu haut
c'est beau c'est beau ce placement de
billets alors ce jeu est gratuit et
inutile de préciser
personne n'aurait payé pour ça
nous sommes maintenant avoir laissé
jouer brad pitt il s'est vite barre et
d'ailleurs il a vu le potentiel du jeu
non on est ce giorno peur et dans nos
moeurs on joue des objets qui font de la
corde à sauter voilà je rappelle bien de
rester c'est quelque chose qui me choque
énormément le corps et je le sais pour
preuve j'en fais jamais pressée nikkei
tout job et voilà et du coup le but
c'est de faire le plus de sous le bois
là le problème c'est que la gangrène ou
coupe littéralement voilà bien par
exemple j'ai fait 3 ce qui est nul
franchement je vais devenir musclé fait
de la corde à sauter tranchante j'avoue
ça motive mais moi je peux par sauter
logiquement ces espaces dans un jeu
comme futur espace tu sautes ouais vous
avez entendu j'ai fait ça pour être
précis et le soya base au daily mail ça
m'énerve et je vais casser un truc rega
c'est un truc de c'est quoi
je veux dire pile dès que j'appuie sur
espace vous avoir ça saute pas pil pil
je suis brad pitt taja [ __ ] cette part
est majoritaire une musique la muga et
et si on faisait une musique s'est
grossi d'être berd pour la loi la pire
idée de l'histoire de ma chaise je vais
tourner le micro vers le clavier ok on
va enregistrer
ok là je suis en train d'isoler chaque
sont un parent de manière faire quelque
chose de colossal la barre espace la
barre espace une petite touche la grosse
basse voilà vous avez peur qu'avec ça on
va atteindre malades
[Musique]
ok les amis après une heure de travail
acharné au piège d'une vidéo où j'ai
préféré faire un sort que durée des jeux
mais je suis personne de résultats
attention on écoute
soyez indulgents merci c'est parti i'm
in love with you ballet bon squeeze
tâche nc du gaming n'as tu fais plus
gaming c'est n'importe quoi
walla walla walla tu vas être capable
toi tes couilles du attire à nantes ou
d'écouteurs dante à manger en troisième
et tu fais le malin honnêtes gens car à
marit xvie que ouais je rentre à jouer
un [ __ ] de poupées je m'amuse à faire
la circulation mon gars voilà finalement
si elle pas été intubé à ce que j'aurais
fait ça on ne sait pas bien si des fois
ils s'impatientent et du coup il y aura
aussi les passagers devaient pas dit oui
je joue moins vas-y toi pas toi passe
soit pas soit parce allait passer mais
non mes mecs des foyers des bus qui
arrivait il sèche l'agent de police
escobar le mec mais ça demande trop de
ressources de ses routes le monde et a
même temps il sait est un tel héros x 28
il n'assume pas et voilà worth trafic
conducteur est mort ça ça veut dire
abonnez vous l'achète de squeeze
l'incroyable et voilà le mec qui
s'impatientent il part tout seul mais
crytek sur la route qu un flic fellah
circulent il n'y a pas de chemin
patienter je passe mon gars le gars qui
tape un sprint site rattrape pas ce que
ça implique un peu benêt rythme un coup
dans la nuque mon pote et ont fait mieux
là on fait mieux non on a fait bien fait
180 ou ne bien c'est super dur mais
c'est super bien je suis content je vous
ai montré un jeu qui est pas mal mais
j'en ai encore un teint jeu on joue un
[ __ ] d'aspirateurs mais qu'il va
falloir aspects mais genre qui part en
coulisses puis apparemment ils espèrent
puissant quand ça joue par contre ok
juste à le prendre à le bouger d'accord
est ce que vous mettez les vidéos de
bruit d'aspirateur sur youtube pour vous
endormir
ça marche hyper bien aux classes il faut
que jaspers à ce trou bleu à un média
faut que je branche mec voilà j'allume
la et ben voila auquel j'aspire un truc
bleus échouent à l'envers le tube bleus
ça a boosté absence d'esprit je vais
aspirer tout et n'importe quoi derrière
voilà
je vous ai parlé d'un excellent jeu
vidéo à quel moment j'ai menti
regardez c'est pas un [ __ ] de jeux
vidéo la physique est trop bien faire et
regarder comme ça aspire heureusement
que j'ai pas fait d'école commerce vous
regarde j'aurais rien vendu j'aimerais
bien inspiré la hâte et la maison
entière je suis sûr que c'est la chute
si c'est la chute fait émerger de cette
vidéo de cette dame est très clairement
que les choses soient claires à faux je
vais retrouver ce qui est sur la table
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais c'est même
la vidéo c'est incroyable allez allez
oui on va ce ps qui avait sur la table
oh il y avait un mouton ce québec et sa
demie un truc bleus a ressassé à booster
mon aspim adultes malades
oh [ __ ] what the fuck
mais non c'est quoi ce délire quoi les
objets sont vivants a monté la spire
tout
c'est quoi ça
puis c'est quoi cette vidéo c'est quoi
ce mardi de merde bande d'amis j'ai
envie de vous dire que c'est la fin de
cette vidéo
et tant mieux on est content qu'elle se
disperse choses à plus de garder cette
vallée mais comme d'habitude en fait
j'adore les mini jeux comme ce qu'on a
fait aujourd'hui mais je pensais qu'il
serait quand même chacun un petit peu
plus long et qu'ils auraient chacun un
intérêt un peu plus grand bah c'était
clairement pas le cas c'est scandaleux
mais ça va plus la vidéo scandaleuse on
va l'appeler au juste qu'une médiation
ait l'idée ça en gros plan comme ça ça
fera une flèche rouge fera plein de vue
comme ça alors sauve très vite pour une
vidéo de bien meilleure qualité
forcément viaggio tout le monde puisse
i'm in love with you buy me love with
you baril